you I believe are directing another
Marvel property coming up I'm sure
you're in prep mode right now
um what was it what is it like actually
getting the keys to the Fantastic Four
um and being the person who's gonna
bring that to screen in the MCU I have
loved these characters since I was a kid
um and so it is a huge joy to be able to
work with them spend time with them
every day to bring them into the MCU
um is also a huge Joy um so it's it's
that it's just the excitement of being
the kid who who found them you know when
I was six seven eight and now being able
to work with them on the big screen is
it's amazing you had such a successful
with long division it's like I mean it's
an incredible series what can you sort
of talk about what you learned making
one division working with Marvel that
you are now applying to making FF and a
big feature film Marvel's a wonderful
place to work I was thrilled to be able
to come back and work with them because
even though they produce the biggest
movies it's a very small family of
people that you're collaborating with
and they're all lovely people
um who are passionate about what they do
and so
um you are working with huge film fans
everyone is making the same movie you're
all moving in the same direction and and
that's just a joy and it's not very
often that that happens especially when
you're dealing with something on a
really large scale like the FF it's it's
really fun to be back you know when you
join something for the first time like I
did on One Division you're just meeting
everybody for the first time now it's
feels like you're you're spending time
with your family which is wonderful and
uh and so it's it's a great uh it's a
great office to show up to every day I'm
a lot of time but I'd like to just ask
one more thing if you don't mind Marvel
has all these upcoming projects and I'm
curious if you went did you say to them
I want FF did they say to you are you
interested in any of these upcoming
films like how did you land on FF versus
say an Avengers movie FF was just the
the film that made the most sense in the
conversation
um you know it's it's the it's the one
that I think I
um naturally gravitate towards um you
know there's there's the reason I love
Star Trek I'm sure is a big part of why
I love the Fantastic Four they are they
share a great sense of optimism and the
idea of looking to the stars and
Technology can solve everything and
coming together as a family either a
real family in the case of FF or the
family that you that you find in the
case of the Enterprise and so there's
just a lot of uh a lot of things about
the property that appealed to me and I'm
thrilled that I was able to to be the
one that that could do it